ahora vamos a hablar acerca de los
lípidos seguramente aquellos de ustedes
que conocen este término lo asocian con
las moléculas de grasa y eso no está
nada mal porque las moléculas de grasa
son una forma muy común de lípidos por
aquí puse un ejemplo de una molécula de
grasa también conocida como un
triglicéridos
y este en particular es un triglicéridos
poli insaturados y bueno ya vimos esto
con mucha profundidad en el vídeo acerca
de la estructura molecular de los
triglicéridos y también en el vídeo de
grasas saturadas insaturadas y grasas
trans lo podemos ver aquí todas las
características que nos dicen que este
es un triglicérido tenemos aquí nuestra
columna de glicerol y nuestros 3 ácidos
grasos o bueno estas tres cosas que
antes eran ácidos grasos y que se
unieron a una molécula de glicerol esto
lo vemos con mucha profundidad en
aquellos vídeos pero los triglicéridos
no son los únicos lípidos ahora qué es
lo que hace que todas estas otras
moléculas de aquí sean consideradas
lípidos que es lo que tienen todos estos
en común con las grasas bueno pues esto
de los lípidos es simplemente un término
general los lípidos son toda una clase
de moléculas que suelen no ser solubles
en agua
suelen agruparse y formar unas bolas
cuando los colocamos en agua
y los lípidos son moléculas que no son
muy solubles en agua
y escogí muy bien mis palabras en lugar
de decir hidrofóbicos dije que no son
muy solubles en agua porque si es cierto
hay muchos lípidos que son tal cual
hidrofóbicos pero también hay algunos
otros lípidos en los cuales una muy
buena parte de la molécula es
hidrofóbica pero la otra de hecho es
hidrofílica y tenemos una palabra para
eso también porque sabemos que muchos
lípidos son hidrofóbicos son moléculas
que realmente huyen del agua ok son
moléculas no polares y por lo tanto se
aglutinan cuando las colocamos en una
solución de agua están estas moléculas
hidrofóbicas pero también hay otros
lípidos en los que una parte de la
molécula es hidrofóbica pero la otra es
hidrofílica y esas son las moléculas
antipáticas en las moléculas antipáticas
una parte es hidrofóbica pero la otra es
hidrofílico
un muy buen ejemplo de una molécula
enzimática son los fosfolípidos esta
molécula de aquí los cuales son
cruciales para la formación de las
membranas celulares y los vamos a ver
muy seguido en biología pero bueno por
el momento estamos por aquí tenemos
estas otras moléculas y podemos ponernos
a pensar en qué partes de estas
moléculas son hidrofóbicas y qué partes
son hidrofílicas cuando nos fijamos en
las grasas por aquí podemos ver que hay
muchas cadenas de carbono las cuales son
hidrofóbicas pero no vemos por ningún
lado un elemento polar ok por aquí
tenemos estos oxígenos pero están
enlazados con carbonos y si los oxígenos
son muy electro negativos así es que
podríamos tener algunas pequeñas cargas
parciales por aquí pero el carbono es
bastante electro negativo ok es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno así es
que aquí
y no se van a poder formar enlaces de
hidrógeno
ok como se formarían si tuviéramos algún
grupo hidroxilo por ahí si éste fuera un
alcohol y bueno estas cadenas de
carbonos son muy hidrofóbicas lo cual
hace que esta molécula sea no muy
soluble en agua y se aglutinen si las
llegas a colocar en una solución de agua
bueno ahora vamos con esta molécula de
aquí que por cierto la clasificaríamos
como un esther porque por aquí tenemos
un grupo funcional esther ok tenemos un
oxígeno con un doble enlace hacia un
carbono el cual además está enlazado a
un oxígeno que está enlazado a una
cadena de carbonos gay este carbono de
aquí también está enlazado a otra cadena
de carbonos esto claramente berzero
hidrofóbico esta molécula de aquí es uno
de los principales constituyentes de la
cera de abeja ok esto de aquí forman
parte de la cera
abeja y bueno si alguna vez has lidiado
con seda de abeja o bueno de hecho con
cualquier tipo de cera todas las ceras
se consideran lípidos y seguro has
podido observar que no son solubles en
agua de hecho muchas veces utilizan cera
para evitar que el agua penetre alguna
cosa y este no es el único constituyente
de la cera de abeja pero sí es uno de
los principales componentes y es un
lípido bueno y ahora vamos con esta
molécula de aquí por aquí tenemos un
anillo de 6 carbonos y luego tenemos
otro anillo de 6 carbonos y otro anillo
de 6 carbonos y finalmente un anillo de
5 carbonos ahora esta estructura de aquí
donde tenemos estos tres anillos de 6
carbonos y luego el anillo de 5 carbonos
en esta configuración esta es una de las
características típicas de los
esteroides y en la cultura popular
generalmente nos referimos a los
esteroides
como esas sustancias que utilizan
algunos fisicoculturistas para agrandar
sus músculos y que se vean mucho más
grandes pero en términos de química
cuando nos referimos a esteroides nos
referimos a un ponche de moléculas ok es
un grupo de moléculas que comparten esta
estructura de aquí aunque yo en la que
tenemos un anillo de 6 carbonos luego
otro anillo de 6 carbonos y unido otro
anillo de 6 carbonos pero con esta
orientación y finalmente otro anillo de
5 carbonos también con esta orientación
ahora este esteroide en particular que
estamos viendo aquí tiene un grupo
hidroxilo así es que también va a ser un
alcohol y cuando tenemos un esteroide
que además es alcohol le llamamos es
terol
este rol y ahora este este rol en
particular has estado escuchando un
montón acerca de él este esteroide en
particular es el colesterol y bueno el
colesterol generalmente es visto como
algo muy malo y hay muchas personas
tratando de bajar sus niveles de
colesterol pero en realidad es una
molécula que es vital para el buen
funcionamiento de nuestras células y
además es una molécula precursora para
nuestras hormonas las cuales hacen que
tú seas tú por otro lado aquí tenemos
otro esteroide y este es la testosterona
y aquí en la testosterona también
podemos ver esta estructura
característica de los esteroides
ok tenemos aquí nuestro anillo de 6
carbonos y bueno aquí tenemos un doble
enlace aunque en el colesterol lo
teníamos en otro lugar y luego tenemos
otro anillo de 6 carbono y otro anillo
de 6 carbono y finalmente el anillo de 5
carbonos
por aquí ya no tenemos el grupo o h aquí
tenemos un oxígeno con un doble enlace a
este carbono lo cual está formando un
grupo carbon hilo pero seguimos teniendo
un grupo h nada más que ahora se
encuentra por aquí ahora la testosterona
es un producto derivado del colesterol
así es que es una hormona esteroide y
bajamos por acá y aquí tenemos otra
hormona esteroide la cual se llama
cortisol y por aquí podemos ver la
estructura de característica de los
esteroides tenemos aquí un anillo de 6
carbonos por aquí tenemos un doble
enlace tenemos otro anillo de 6 carbonos
y otro anillo de 6 carbonos y finalmente
un anillo de 5 carbonos así es que todas
estas tienen esta estructura base de los
esteroides pero luego tienen estas otras
cosas que las hacen diferentes por aquí
esta parte de la molécula es diferente
de esta parte
es diferente también de esta parte y
bueno tenemos esto por acá para que
puedas visualizar a las moléculas en
tercera dimensión porque hay una
verdadera molécula no se va a ver de
esta forma exactamente y bueno de hecho
hablar de cómo se ven las cosas a un
nivel molecular suena bastante extraño
porque la luz en esas dimensiones se
comporta de formas extrañas podríamos
llegar a decir que se ve de esta forma
aunque este es un modelo de barras y
esferas pero si nos pusiéramos a pensar
en el espacio que ocupan los átomos
estamos pensando en algo más por este
estilo ok la molécula se va a ver un
poco más así en el espacio donde las
bolas blancas son los hidrógenos las
bolas grises son los carbonos y las
bolas rojas son oxígenos así es que
también podemos decir que el cortisol se
ve más o menos así cuando estamos
tratando de visualizar el espacio que
ocupan los átomos
ahora también tenemos que hablar acerca
de las moléculas antipáticas y los
fosfolípidos son sus ejemplos más
conocidos ahora los fosfolípidos tienen
bastantes cosas en común con los
peligros heridos sobre todo porque
tienen aquí esta columna de 3 carbonos
este es un carbono este es otro carbono
y este también es un carbono y además
cada uno de estos carbonos está enlazado
con un oxígeno así es que esta molécula
puede provenir de una molécula de
glicerol y además dos de los carbonos
están enlazados con ácidos grasos al
igual que los triglicéridos
pero luego el tercer carbono en lugar de
estar enlazado con otro ácido graso como
sucedería en los triglicéridos el último
carbono está enlazado con un grupo
fosfato así es que esto de aquí es un
grupo fosfato y luego aquí tenemos una r
que denota a alguna cadena orgánica
ahora cuando empezamos a hablar acerca
de las moléculas antipáticas dijimos que
tenían su parte hidrofóbica y su parte
hidrofílica así es que en esta molécula
cuál es la parte hidrofóbica estas
cadenas de carbonos són hidrofóbicas
hidrofóbicas mientras que el grupo
fosfato tiene una carga y cualquier
molécula que tenga una carga se va a
disolver muy bien en el agua así es que
esta parte de la molécula de aquí va a
ser hidrofílica ok se va a sentir
atraída por el agua ahora este es solo
un tipo de fosfolípidos ok estas cadenas
pueden ser diferentes por aquí tenemos
la cadena de un ácido graso
monoinsaturado y por acá tenemos la
cadena de un ácido graso saturado la
verdad acabo de inventar estas cadenas
por supuesto que estas pueden ser
completamente diferentes dependiendo del
fosfolípido del cual estés hablando pero
esta característica de tener una cabeza
y draw
y un cuerpo hidrofóbico hace que estos
fosfolípidos sean excelentes para las
membranas celulares porque como te
puedes imaginar si tenemos aquí nuestra
cabeza hidrofílica y nuestro cuerpo
hidrofóbico ahora vamos a dibujar muchos
de estos fosfolípidos así es que voy a
empezar dibujando todas las cabezas
hidrofílicas y luego dibujamos muy
rápidamente todas las colas hidrofóbicas
nunca hay todas estas cadenas
hidrofóbicas y bueno esta estructura de
bicapa de fosfolípidos ok esta bicapa
fósforo lipídica es cómo se construyen
las membranas celulares si por ejemplo
aquí tenemos agua o bueno cosas
compuestas por agua y esto podría ser
adentro de la célula
y esto podría hacer adentro de la célula
y esto de acá podría ser afuera de la
célula y entonces cuando tenemos estos
fosfolípidos la cabeza hidrofílica se va
a sentir atraída por el agua mientras
que estas colas hidrofóbicas estas
cadenas de hidrocarbonos se van a
orientar de esta forma para no estar en
contacto con el agua aunque hay para
estar lejos del agua y de esta forma
únicamente las cabezas que son los
grupos de fosfato están interactuando
con el agua y así es como se forma una
muy buena barrera para las células y la
vamos a estudiar muy a fondo cuando nos
adentremos un poco más en biología pero
bueno espero que esto te dé una mejor
idea de qué es lo que son los lípidos y
también de cuáles son los diferentes
tipos de lípidos que hay